blow jab fan my doctor told me that the
best way they keep your sperm count high
is nice cool air flow let's actually see
how these work though like and once
somebody use this one I'm pretty sure
that then belongs to that person forever
well there's a letter hi Sam hi we're
excited that you want to be part of the
[ __ ] family I mean that you want to
test out the [ __ ] fan we install
batteries so you can get right to it
well it works best when the exhaust tube
is placed inside the underwear well
we've been using 3ds max for years but
Peter here is using blender for a couple
shots
break it down for how you made those
those fingies in blender okay so let's
do something nice thing about blender is
that it's 100% free anyone can download
this and learn how to use it and it's
very good this is free yeah it's
entirely free it's open source really
yeah dude that means I can get yeah I
don't know about that
I can try each time I see blender though
it's like look why are we using 3ds max
it's got like all the features and all
the plugins all the things you need like
physical rendering in physics basically
we have a shot where Mike gets his
fingers chopped off
we filmed actual finger plates in case
we wanted to do in 2d but Peter went all
the way and did in 3d by modeling
fingers I downloaded a handful of them a
TF 3d em calm oh yes it's that's what we
do though it's like you download the
model hopefully it's already textured
then you make it work for yourself
that's cool but at first was I
downloaded a 3d model of a hand brought
that into blender I took the fingers off
as you can see here separated those I
animated them flying away and what I did
to make the fingers look all wobbly was
I did a soft body simulation which means
blender takes the mesh of the fingers
and it stimulates it a like yellow just
letting a wiggle exactly yeah I
basically have two materials present on
this which
the finger skin itself material and then
the blood material on the bottom of the
fingers so we're looking for a concept
artist for the Beast or pocket now it's
important that we have concept art put
together for this because you're going
into a meeting to try to explain the
movie or the idea to somebody you need
to give them some foundation because
honestly it's your job as the filmmakers
to be imagining what this world looks
like and then it's your job to
communicate this to a producer for
example or an investor you don't have a
completed script you know at least flesh
it out with here's the overall idea
here's a bunch of cool art here's where
our inspirations come from and here's an
example of our work it's a very
particular kind of beast that requires a
particular kind of artist we're just
trying to figure out how we go about
reaching out to the right person the
thing that makes this shot work the best
is the fact that the lighting was so
distinct in the original shine got like
a very bright yeah a very bright white
light on the other side that sells it
more than anything just the matching
lighting so what's separating the skin
from the blood is a blood map which I
made myself took my little paintbrush
and I brushed the buttons of the fingers
and I told blender to use that to
distinguish between skin and blood only
the bottoms of the fingers have blood on
them so I made this little weird janky
tendon model and then I applied another
soft body simulation of that now we got
some weird tendrils Lionel the last
thing I did was do a particle simulation
for some blood that's the model right
there yeah that's pretty friendly right
it took me 24 hours I did not leave the
studio seriously though it's really good
though this whole script and stuff we've
been working on it's been evolving and
it's gotten everything from this whole
like tether stuff to like space [ __ ]
it is but he keeps undergoing like
serious heavy iterations it is still
that post-apocalyptic beauty and decent
story but we finally kind of honed in on
the vibe and style of it so that's like
almost like a horror movie but at first
words like people are getting killed you
kidnapped what's going on you know so
it's like mysterious and spooky and
plague-ridden environment it kind of
takes a step or two in the fantasy
direction of like a little bit machine a
little bit natural you know so it's not
like scaly lizard stuff it's good balsam
ideas here
literally outlines silhouettes sketch
like doesn't look like quality's not key
how do you read that like oh you're like
feeling I just think about that you know
so like your head shapes many
disproportionate and way likes you know
like the creepy factor well it works
best when the exhaust tube is placed
inside the underwear you just do that
dip it in only someone that lives in
Florida with it
[Laughter]
okay so here's the funny thing here's
the funny thing here's the funny thing
this is incredibly effective Florida man
named Oh Florida man here's the here's
the headline Florida man
here's Swamp a nice Carmichael feet feel
how cool the air is use your sleeve to
take the moisture off of there just to
dry it off draft the exhaust board the
starwars evaporation oh man you're just
like a frickin - the moisture farms
Uncle Ben's moisture farm Uncle Ben's
[ __ ] moisture farm fan did you man
I spent most of the day looking at
references doing uh boss silhouettes
trying to get a mixture of mechanical
but somewhat like beasts like organic
Gotham kind of thing not going like Lord
of the Rings but like a golem like a
giant stone monster yeah once you see it
up close then you see all the robotic
stuff but it supposed to be kind of
hidden so it's pretty it's pretty
challenging so I had like I did a bunch
of drawings and stuff my specialty is
more starboard but yeah like I could do
this all day like I get lost in this
stuff all day crank music and then just
what kind of music do you usually listen
to when you do or this is the end by the
doors I almost put you in a trance like
you're not thinking as much you're just
drawing and lessons immune to the same
time those moments where you're just in
there if I could be in that other type I
would yeah it's pretty awesome
well I just been taking care of mostly
just management on this project a few
shots here and there like much as sparks
coming out here Peters actually been
doing most of the most of the effects on
the repeaters right now check out this
dragon he's been doing the prequel stuff
blender man
this isn't a rendering though so I don't
know where Peter has gone Peter I think
I saw him go to the back like
oh my god he's frozen solid I
specifically didn't put the heatsinks
there
[Music]